what what's good advice for to try to
protect yourself from this increasingly
dangerous world of cyber attacks again
educate yourself that you understand
that there is a threat first you have to
realize that then then you're going to
step up and you're going to do stuff a
little bit more sometimes I just think I
take that to a little bit extreme I
remember one time uh uh my mom called me
and she was uh screaming that uh I woke
up this morning and I just clicked on a
link and now my phone is making weird
noises and I was like
throw your phone in a glass of water
just put in a glass of water right now
and she's I I made my mom cry it was not
a pleasant thing
um so sometimes I go to a little
extremes on those ones but but
understanding is a risk and making it a
little bit more a little more difficult
to become a victim I mean just
understanding certain things
um you know simple things like you know
as we add more internet of things to
people's houses I mean how many Wi-Fi
networks do people have it's normally
just one and you're bumping your phones
and giving your password to be able to
come to visit set up a guest Network set
up something you can change every 30
days simple little things like that
um you know I hate to remind you but
change your passwords I mean I feel like
I'm a broken record again but just make
it more difficult for others to
victimize you and then don't use the
same password everywhere that that yes I
mean I still I still know people that do
that I mean FM got popped last week two
weeks ago and that's 350 million
username and passwords with connected
Twitter accounts Google accounts uh you
know all the different social media
accounts you know that is a treasure
Trove for the next two and a half three
years of just using those credentials
everywhere
um using you'll learn even if it's not
the right password you learn people's
password Styles you know bad guys are
making portfolios out of people uh you
know we're figuring out how people
generate their passwords and kind of you
know figuring and then it's easier to
crack their password
you know we're making a dossier on each
person it's 350 million dossiers just in
that one had Yahoo there was a half a
billion
so the the thing a hacker would do with
that is try to find all the link low
hanging fruit like have some kind of
program that
yeah evaluates the strength of the
passwords
and then finds the weak ones and that
means that this person is probably the
kind of person that would use the same
password across multiple or even just
write a program and do that remember the
ring hack a couple a year ago that's all
it was is credential stuffing so ring
the security system by default had to
factor but didn't turn it on and they
also had uh don't try unlimited tries to
log into my account you can lock it out
after 10. by default not turned on
because it's not convenient for people
you know ring you know it's like I want
people to stick these little things up
and have Security in their house uh but
you know cyber security don't make it
inconvenient then people will not buy
our product
that's how they got hacked they want to
say that it's insecure and got hacked
into reputational harm right there for
ring but they didn't it was just
credential stuffing people bought
username and passwords on the black
market and
just wrote a bot that just went through
ring and used every one of them to maybe
one percent hit but that's a big hit
to the number of ring users you know you
can use also password managers to make
to make the changing of the passwords
easier
um
to make you can choose the difficulty
the number of special characters the
length of it and all that
um my favorite things on websites
he yell at you for your password being
too long or having too many special care
or like uh or yeah you're not allowed to
have this special character or something
you can only use these three special
characters it's a you know do you
understand how password cracking works
if you specifically tell me which past
which special characters I can use I
wanna like I honestly just want to have
a one-on-one meeting like late at night
with the engineer that programmed that
because that's that's like an intern I
just want to have a sit down meeting
yeah I made my parents switch Banks once
because the security was so poor I was
like you just you can't have money here
but then there's also like the zero day
attacks like uh we mentioned I mentioned
before the uh the qnep nas that got
hacked uh luckily I didn't have anything
private on there
um but it really woke me up until like
okay so like if you take everything
extremely seriously
unfortunately for the end users there's
nothing you do about zero day it's you
know there's this you have no control
over that I mean it's a it's a the
engineers that made the software don't
even know about it now let's talk about
one days
um so there's a patch now out there for
the security so if you're not updating
your systems for these security badges
if it's just not on you
um my father-in-law has such an old
iPhone you can't security patch it
anymore so you know and I tell him I
said you know this is what you're
missing out on this is what you're
exposing yourself to because
um you know we talked about that
powerful tool that uh the the how we
found Ross Albrecht gmail.com well bad
guys are using that too it's called you
know it used to be called Google Dorking
now it's I think it's named kind of
Google hacking by the community
um you can go in you know and find a
vulnerability read about the white paper
what's wrong with that that software and
then you can go on the internet and find
all of the computers that are running
that outdated software and there's your
list there's your target list yeah I
know the vulnerabilities they're running
again not making a Playbook here but you
know that's how easy it is to to find
your targets and that's what that's what
the bad guys are doing then the reverse
is tough it's much tougher but it's
still doable which is like first find
the target like if you have specific
targets
uh to to you know hack into a Twitter
account for example much harder that's
probably social engineering right that's
probably the best way probably if you if
you want something specific to that I
mean if you really want to go far you
know
if you're targeting a specific person
you know how hard is it to get into
their office and put a you know a little
device USB device in line with their
Mouse who checks how their Mouse is
plugged in and you can for 40 bucks on
the black market you can buy a key
logger that just USB then the mouse
plugs right into it it looks like an
extension on the mouse if you can even
find it you can buy the the stuff with a
mouse inside of it uh and just plug it
into somebody's computer as there's a
key logger that lives in there and calls
home sends everything you want so I mean
and it's cheap yeah in grad school
um a program to build a bunch of key
loggers it was fascinating tracking
Mouse just for uh what I was doing as
part of the research uh I was doing
to uh uh to see if by the Dynamics of
how you type
and how you move the mouse you can tell
who the person is oh wow that's like
um it's called the active authentication
or like it's basically Biometrics that's
not using bio uh just to see how
identifiable that is so it's fascinating
to study that but it's also fascinating
how damn easy it is to install key
loggers so I I think is is in natural
what happens is you realize how many
vulnerabilities there are in this world
you do that when you understand bacteria
and viruses you realize they're
everywhere in the same way with uh I'm
talking about biological ones and then
you realize that all the vulnerabilities
that are out there one of the things
I've noticed quite a lot is
how many people don't log out of their
computers
just how easy physical access the
systems actually is
uh like in a lot of places in this world
and I'm not talking about private homes
I'm talking about companies especially
large companies it seems quite trivial
in certain places that I've been to to
walk in and have physical access to a
system and that's depressing to me it is
it just I laugh because uh one of my my
partners at naxo that I work at now
um he worked at a big company like you
would know the name as soon as I told
you I'm not going to say it um but the
guy who owned the company and the
company has his name on it
um didn't want to ever log into a
computer just annoyed the [ __ ] out of
him so they hired a person that stands
next to his computer when he's not there
and that's his physical security
you see that's good that's that's pretty
good actually so yeah I mean I guess if
you could afford to do that at least
you're taking your security seriously I
feel like there's a lot of people in
that case would just not have a login
yeah no the security team there had to
really work around to make that work uh
non-compliant with company policy but
that's that's interesting the the key
log is there's there's a lot of there's
just a lot of threats yeah I mean a lot
of ways to get in yeah I mean so you
can't sit around and worry about someone
physically gaining access to your
computer with keylogger and stuff like
that
um you know if you're traveling to a
foreign country and you work for the FBI
then yeah you do you pick little you
know sometimes some countries you would
bring a fake laptop just to see if they
stole it or accessed it I really want
especially in this modern day to just
create a lot of clones in myself that
generate
Lex sounding things and just get put so
much information out there actually
docks myself
all across the world and then you're not
a Target I guess just put it out there
I've always said that though like we do
these searches in FBI houses and stuff
like that if someone just got like a box
load of like 10 terabyte drives and just
encrypting them oh my God you know how
long the FBI would spin their wheels
trying to get that data off there be
insane awesome so just give them you
don't even know which one you're looking
for yeah
that's true that's true so it's like uh
me printing like a treasure map to a
random location just get people to go on
Goose goose chases
yeah uh what what about operating system
what what have you found uh what's the
most secure and what's the least secure
operating system Windows Linux
is there no Universal there's no
Universal Security I mean it changed you
people use anything Max were the most
secure just because they just weren't
out there but now kids have had access
to them so you know it is you know I
know you're a Linux guy I I like Linux
too but you know it's tough to have run
a business on on Linux you know people
want to move more towards the microsofts
and the Googles just because they don't
it's easier to communicate with other
people that maybe are computer guys so
you have to just take what what's best
what's easiest and secure the [ __ ] out
of it as much as you can and just think
about it